hey guys I'm Jess and I'm here with Edie
hello and we can have a chat about Dark
Souls 3 specifically approaching Dark
Souls 3 as a total beginner which I am
to the series and it is not so I have a
bunch of very newbie questions about how
to go about playing it and why is so hot
and how do I not die go for it yes
alright so question number one is what a
fundamental basics should I know about
the Dark Souls Weldon's story so far
before going into Dark Souls 3 my answer
is none to me the story has always been
dressing and the main game has been the
mechanics and that's what you should
focus on you don't need to have played
the previous Dark Souls games to get
into this alrighty so approaching it
from the start you know you pick your
character and class and everything now
all their classes which are more or less
difficult to play for a beginner and how
should I go about choosing one I would
say sort of the traditional sword and
shield classes like the knight and the
warrior are probably the easiest to get
into potted classes to start with are
definitely the magic users so like your
Pyromancer your clerics ones that focus
purely on sort of spells and miracles
and healing and lastly deprived which is
a character that starts at level one
with a club and a shield and no clothes
and that's really for your little expert
like min max stat people a good idea is
to kind of pick a class that you that
seems like it fits your playstyle play a
little bit of the game find a weapon
that you like the attack patterns of and
you like the abilities of and then try
and build your character out to become
more efficient with that so you get to
choose an item to start off with I went
for a ring that was supposedly going to
give me more HP what do you reckons the
best starter items they mostly offer you
consumable items that you can pick up
along the way
so I think the the ring that gives you
more HP is probably a really good pick
first data considering consumables is it
ever worth buying them like a back at
the filing shrine which is basically a
home base or should I just be finding
them and not
my souls I think a good rule of thumb is
it generally don't be stingy with your
souls because you all more often than
not end up losing those souls and
they'll go to waste
anyway so you should spend whatever you
need to make you feel better about going
back out there
that means more grenades and stuff you
know go for it
what would you say are five of the most
crucial combat tips or a few you have to
give me five that you could give a
beginner which apply to most encounters
in the game one don't button mash okay
that's my number one - that's hot
conservative honest yeah yeah this
stamina is obviously a resource in this
game and every action you do whether it
be rolling swinging your sword getting
hit while you're blocking will deplete
your stamina so every move needs to
count number two tip for beginners is
probably keep your shield up at all
times mm-hmm
you never know what's around the corner
what might be hitting you remember that
rolling makes you invincible so rolling
towards an enemy as they swing at you is
a good way of getting up close and
personal getting a hit or two in and
then rolling out while you still have
stamina so always remember that your SS
flask can heal you a good chunk and
always keep an eye on it and when you're
running out of Estus flask uses and you
have a bunch of souls don't be afraid to
just go back the way you came
reeking the latter bonfire start again
go through the enemies that respawned
yeah and then get more Souls to then go
back to base and then level yourself up
we'll get another piece of gear to make
that easier
I guess lastly is to that point watch
the enemies attack know they're sort of
breadth of abilities and what kinds of
tax they might be throwing out and know
how to avoid them so if someone swings
you know they'll have a follow-up swing
more often than not last stuff let's
talk about bosses what is the best way
to take on a bus or what does it always
depend on the different kind of us it
always depends a different kind of boss
because bosses come in all shapes and
sizes from like a tiniest all creature
to the most enormous [ __ ] off being you
I was
your life and it can be very easy to be
intimidated by just the sheer size of
some of these bosses I remember the
first time I played Dark Souls just like
I just had no idea how to hit a dragon
that was like 20 stories tall but just
know that once you get up close you can
hit it and it will do damage like every
other enemy watch it and learn its
attack patterns and know what you might
what might be coming out next if you're
having a [ __ ] time it's always helpful
to just stand up put the game away for
an hour or two or even you know sleep on
it and just come back to it later
because you really need to be in the
right frame of mind to sort of take on a
lot of these challenges sweet well
thanks for the advice and good luck
everyone if you're going to pick up Dark
Souls 3 and deal with the frustration
you